hey guys it's Justine and it has been
quite a while since the new iPhone 14
has come out and I'm so excited because
today we're gonna be doing an update
talking about all the things that I've
loved and also showing you what is on my
iPhone now before we get into that this
portion of the video is sponsored by
MailChimp they are the number one email
marketing and automation platform with
over 12 million customers that send more
than half a billion emails every day
they analyze the data from billions of
emails that they send to offer up
personalized recommendations that help
businesses improve engagement and
revenue why I'm really excited about
partnering with MailChimp is I have been
using them for a really long time now I
haven't recently been active with my
mailing list subscribers but this was
one of the first mailing list companies
that I had ever used when I first
started basically I'm doing any type of
Internet content so if you want to sign
up for my new mailing list I'll put a
link in the description where you can
check it out I'm super excited about
this I have something planned for the
holidays I haven't figured out 100 yet
all what it's going to be but I promise
you it's gonna be pretty cool more and
more for creators I think we're trying
to find other ways to actually get in
touch with people stay connected and
sort of have that one-on-one
relationship so again if you guys want
to check it out I'll put a link in the
description and if you are someone with
a business or you're a creative who is
looking to take their email list to the
next level or maybe even start one for
the first time I definitely recommend
MailChimp you guys can get started at
mailchimp.com and you can also sign up
for my mailing list for a fun surprise
thank you again to MailChimp for
sponsoring a portion of this video so
obviously the iPhone has been out for
quite a while and again the iPhone 14
was not a massive update from the 13 but
some of the things that they did update
in this phone are pretty impressive
obviously we have the upgraded cameras
and now that the satellite features are
finally live I am so excited about this
because this will allow you if you're
ever in a situation where you don't have
access to cell reception and in case of
an emergency satellite will kick in and
you'll be able to call for help I did
get a chance to go and check this out
and really see Hands on how this worked
and it was pretty impressive and as
someone who really enjoys going out and
hiking in very remote places and going
to National parks where there's never
cell reception this is definitely
putting my mind at ease so now some of
the apps that I have been using
obviously are as follows now I started
my phone brand new completely from
scratch because I didn't want any of the
old apps transferred over to my phone so
here's pretty much what my layout looks
like we've obviously have got our
settings the clock I've got my app store
we have our calendar I've got Gmail and
we have Google Maps and Apple Maps I
kind of have them both side by side just
because sometimes I want to use one over
the other and I like knowing that
they're right there in the middle of the
screen I can hit them at any time we've
got our notes YouTube studio and the
YouTube app of course the Tesla app so
that I can use my car I just realized
the other day that it had in the app a
way to beep the horn because I always
loved having a key fob so that's how I
would find my car when it was lost and I
was lost in a parking garage and I was
like this has to have a beep there's got
to be a way to do this and sure enough
there is this is my little Finance
section this is kind of where I have all
of my my crypto and money apps we've got
coinbase helium coinbase pro my rainbow
wallet venmo metamask public Phantom and
of course the coinbase wallet and we've
got some more social media here we've
got Instagram Tick Tock Snapchat and
we've got some smart home apps right
here we've got nest and ring and those
are just to control and see my video
cameras that I have around the office
and at home Power view this is what I
use to open and close my blinds in my
home so those are all automated so I
have a bunch of Lutron lights so I can
control them directly from here goes on
that is what I use to control the
sprinkler system that I have in my
garden so that's something that I didn't
personally set up but yeah I Robot those
are my robotic vacuums and Google home
that also connects to my Nest devices
we've got this Schlage which I use to
control my smart locks nanoleaf those
are to control some of the nanoleaf
light bulbs and I have in my home brava
that is my infrared oven which I think
I've talked about before with you guys
one of my favorite smart home devices
ever Traeger of course we've got a smart
home Grill to go with the smart home
oven I love this Grill so much it's been
so much fun to actually cook out and I'm
not gonna lie I don't even have to lie
because I think you can ask my friends
to vouch for me actually I'm not bad at
grilling they've been pretty impressed
control center this is what I use to
control my Elgato lights that I have on
my streaming desk and washos that is an
app that I use to get my car washed it's
incredible it's like a car wash on
demand say when you want them to come
here and they show up clean your car and
ta-da it's done Aura I think we've
talked about that before it's the aura
ring which mine's actually charging
right now so that's why I'm not wearing
it telegram the phone to make phone
calls I know I don't like that app it's
probably my least favorite app on this
phone which is ironic the phone app on
the phone I don't like it we've got
WhatsApp Discord Spotify and Geno pets
also one of my favorite apps this is my
little Geno pet so he basically tracks
my steps every day then I Bank the steps
and then I use the energy that I've
gained from the steps to level him up
so we're gonna level up our dude just a
little because then I'm gonna Harvest
his energy then he also connects to the
Solana networks I have a habitat on
Solana and then I basically use the
steps and the energy that I've created
to harvest but it's it's a whole thing
if you know you know here's my
productivity folder we've got Google
Sheets docs Microsoft teams WebEx Zoom
LinkedIn and frame IO travel
a bunch of airline apps not that
exciting food
okay I don't know why Home Depot and
FedEx and Zappos is there but they are
cart too good to go resi and blue
bottles we've got some more social
networking here we've got Diablo
Immortal which I was so obsessed with
this game thankfully I'm not as obsessed
because it was a sickness like it's all
I wanted to do I woke up in the morning
played during the day played before I
went to bed so now I'm just like a
casual player I love this game so much
it's so great we've got the Xbox app
Imaging Edge which was what I used to
kind of connect to my cameras and I can
like control them I can take photos by
myself and it all connects right to my
phone so I can actually see a preview of
it it's pretty cool we've also got
Disney plus we've got magic seaweed so I
can you know check the surf uh soothe
aerofit this is a new app that I just
got that actually connects with a device
that measures your lung capacity so you
do daily lung training to increase your
lung capacity and just improve your
overall well-being so that's been pretty
fun true coach is kind of cool so this
is my trainer uses to send me workouts
so we'll connect to that he adds into
workouts and then every day or every
other day there's a work out there that
I can do we've got flow this is a period
tracker it's probably one of the most
important apps on my phone even though
my aura ring and Apple watch will
predict when my next period is I do like
to have that and manually track it
because that's what I've been using for
so long and then we have our DJI go 4
app which I use to connect to my drone
and I guess last but not least I didn't
even talk about these little apps down
here we've got our text messages our
mail Safari and the camera and that's it
those are all of the apps that I
currently have on my iPhone so the case
that I decided to rock is this yellow
one it's just so bright and cheery and
the weather in Los Angeles has started
getting dim it's getting dark so early
and this case just really makes me happy
I also picked up recently the purple and
kind of like the it's like a gray green
kind of color which is really pretty as
well I could go get them and show them
to you like why don't I just get up we
only have have to talk about it like I
can show it to you just look at these
things have you seen a more beautiful
thing yeah God I love this color scheme
it's so nice so this is the front screen
that I've been using and this is the
background that I've been using that
kind of matches it and the reason that I
have been using this one so much is I've
been traveling a lot and I love being
able to add wherever I am or wherever
I'm going this changes depending upon
where you are so it's really cool to
kind of get this Dynamic view of
wherever it is that I'm going or where I
am and then sometimes on the plane it
actually updates um I also don't like
that 452 is when the Sun is setting no
no so yeah that's pretty much been my
experience for the past couple of months
with the new iPhone 14. the new iPhone
14 plus has also been released so that
is now out so now the entire lineup is
out there so I'm sure for some of you
there may be some iPhones on your
holiday wish list so as a Santa iJustine
or I Santa I Miss Claus I'm not sure
where I'm going with this I hope that we
can grant your wish from the North Pole
well thank you for watching I hope you
guys enjoyed this video I would love to
hear from you guys though what are your
top used apps on your phones leave those
in the comments below and don't forget
to sign up for my mailing list I can't
wait to get a chance to chat with you
guys and share with you my little
holiday surprise it's gonna be great if
you haven't already please subscribe to
my YouTube channel hit the Bell to be
notified when I post new videos and I
will see you guys in the comments below